you've corroborated what we knew that
the there are record numbers of people
crossing the channel 300 in 2018 more
than 24 000 now
um is it is the point that you were
really trying to make that you think
that pretty patel is being too soft on
undocumented migrants
uh good morning trevor good to join you
no the point i'm making is that the home
secretary is comprehensively failing in
this policy area and it appears the
prime minister agrees because he seems
to be putting the minister for the
cabinet office
in charge of a review of this but the
home secretary's failure is a dangerous
failure we have thousands of people
risking their lives in these most
dangerous sea lanes the most dangerous
sea crossing in the world and if the
rate continues as it is at the moment if
the rate of increase from last year to
this year is repeated again next year
we'll have as many people risking their
lives in the channel as there are people
in pretty patel's constituency her
incompetence on this issue is dangerous
yes but let's just get clear why you
think pretty patella is failing is she
failing because she's not getting people
ashore safely
or is she failing because she's letting
anybody assure at all
what what is the problem with what she's
doing that she's failing to stop the
people getting here or that she's
allowing people to be endangered
let me tell you exactly what the problem
is and exactly what i would be doing as
home secretary in stead
we need first of all to have a workable
deal with the french authorities which
predi patel doesn't have all she's
interested in is diplomatic spats with
the french government that isn't uh what
we need what we actually need is to be
looking not only at the coast not only
at the coastal patrols but we need to be
looking as well as what what is
happening away from the coast disrupting
these vile people smugglers on the
routes that they facilitate people do
not become refugees in northern france
this problem is about a far wider issue
than that second but
second the government should reintroduce
the dub scheme which is a safe route for
unaccompanied children three thousand
unaccompanied children was meant to help
close then after 480 and finally thirdly
let me just finish on this point the
government should reinstate the
international aid budget the 0.7
and the department for international
development which tackled why
people become displaced from their homes
in the first place so that's what i'd be
doing and that i'm afraid of what pretty
patel is failing on at the moment
yes forgive me i i still don't really
understand what your objective is here
is your objective to provide
safe travel for 25 000 people who want
to land in britain or is your objective
to stop 25 000 people who want to land
in britain uh coming short the beaches
my objective is to stop people risking
their lives in the english channel in
the first place one person risking their
life in the english channel is one too
many i i've been to dover
you wanna you basically you wanna stop
you want to stop the
you want to stop people coming here
that's the basic that's the bottom line
here
no
hang on no that that's that's not quite
what i'm saying at all i've already
mentioned the issue of safe routes and
i've already said that would be a
fundamental part of what i would be
doing as home secretary but what i'm
also saying to you trevor is that we
have to prevent people risking their
lives in the english channel because
that is what is happening on a virtual
daily basis at the moment and pretty
patel is comprehensively failing to
prevent that from happening
okay well
there's a perfectly reasonable way to
stop people risking their lives which is
that when our uh our boats our uh navy
sees them in the channel take them
aboard and bring them back to
back back to dover so that's fine 25 000
people landing on the beaches that's
okay
uh saving lives in the english channel
is of course okay and by the way people
who demonize the royal national lifeboat
institute for saving lives at sea should
be absolutely ashamed of themselves
frankly once people's lives are at risk
nobody's doing that here see we have to
make sure we save those lives the point
i'm making is we need our policy to be
calibrated in such a way that people are
not risking their lives in the channel
in the first place and that is where
pretty patel is failing comprehensively
all right well let's let's just talk
about um the proposals that uh you put
out today um when you talk about safe
and legal routes to help prevent people
from using people trafficking route
an example of such i mean how does that
work
well i'll give you i'll give you two
specific examples trevor let me give you
the first example which i mentioned a
moment or two ago which is the dubs
scheme named after alf dubs who escaped
nazi persecution on the kinder transport
in the 1930s
that should be reinstated everybody
across parliament understood that would
have helped three thousand unaccompanied
children the government closed it down
after only 480
that needs to be reinstated secondly we
really do need to see the government's
action on the afghanistan resettlement
scheme we've had operation meeting where
our armed forces did a magnificent job
in that airlift
from kabul airport but what we've seen
from the government is nothing in terms
of how they propose now to help those
people that they've promised to help but
my worry is that unless the government
gets that right that safe route right we
are going to end up in a situation with
a possible tragedy next year of seeing
people from afghanistan in the english
channel unless the government gets this
right now
of dub scheme was as you say uh in a
sense inspired by his own experience as
uh a child of the kindertransport
uh who escaped um
nazi occupation and so on um but what is
different here is that the children that
we're seeing in the channel have their
parents with them um
if the scheme were implemented it would
also follow by the way it wouldn't just
be three thousand children it would be
their parents wouldn't it um and that
that's that's you that would be part of
your scheme with it
well look there's already we're already
looking at in the issue of family
reunion but let's not just mix up uh
issues here because the people who've
all right it's just a natural
consequence of what you suggested isn't
it
well it's certainly family reunion is
something that is already being
considered and looked at but the point
i'm making is we mustn't mix up issues
here in the sense that those who've
already arrived here trevor that you've
just referred to
clearly the issue for them and 98 of
those who arrive claim asylum is that
their asylum claim is dealt with quickly
and fairly and one of the other major
problems to this government is what
they've done to the asylum system over
the past 11 years if you go back to 2014
87 of asylum claims were dealt with
within six months by 2019 that had
fallen to 20 the government made a
catastrophic blunder in taking away the
six-month performance target in our
asylum system and what we're left with
now is a situation in our asylum system
where claims are taking in some cases
many years it's not helpful to anyone in
our asylum system it's not helpful to
the taxpayer it is a failure of this
conservative government
um i don't know if you heard the health
secretary uh talking about
uh
first of all the uh essentially
institutional systemic racism in health
services not just in the uk across the
world and i wondered what your thought
was about that
and secondly the prospect of
more people than the 5.9 million um who
are waiting for treatment in the nhs and
pick your either those two issues
well firstly in terms of the
disproportionate
impact of health care on black asian
minority ethnic communities that's
something labor has been raising
throughout the pandemic kia sama
appointed baroness doreen lawrence to
look at this and the next labor
government will introduce a new race
equality act to look at precisely those
disproportionate uh outcomes uh travel i
think that is absolutely essential and
top priority that we do as regards the
national health service in england this
winter we are in a situation where this
week the government with completely the
wrong priorities will try to drive
through another yet another top-down
reorganization when we need urgent
action in our national health service
now here in wales where i'm speaking to
you from where labour is in government
we've set out a winter plan we are
focusing here in wales the labour party
on that
investment to go into social services to
reduce pressure on the nhs throughout
the winter the government for england
doesn't have a plan to deal with this
and should be putting its foot to the
floor put the pedal down on the booster
program to get that booster program
really up to half a million jobs a day
that will be one of the most effective
ways of reducing pressure on the nhs in
england this winter